[Musik]
es ist ja schließlich wertet wie er zu
der eigenen kind
sie wachsen das herz so bekannten
stärken und schwächen 90 grad als junger
musik und meditation eine emotionelle
platzieren wir so viel zeit und energie
und vor allem sauber investiert hat dass
es ein stück fein sauber wird diese
wesen die haben sie ja kuba genannt
geliebt wie sein eigen fleisch und blut
sind nur noch knochen skelette von
dinosaurier und gestorben vor 150
millionen jahren zehn der riesen in
seinem museum hat er selber ausgegraben
blt oder baby toni
sie sind teil seiner familie geworden um
sie sind teil einer sammlung von
weltformat
warum verschreibt einer sein leben toten
tieren davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
eine ehemalige spinnerei im zürcher
oberland nicht der ort an dem man als
erstes ein dinosaurier museum vermuten
würde
auch kobe sievers idee hier eines
aufzubauen taten anfangs viele als
spinnerei absehbar ist keine akademisch
ausgebildete paläontologe sondern
autodidaktin der hippie zeit machte er
experimentalfilme dann betriebe mit
seinem vater ein mineralien geschäft
über das sammeln und handeln von
fossilien kam er zu den dinosauriern
heute genießt das museum einen
internationalen ruf auch unter
wissenschaftlern und der spieler hat
einen ehrendoktortitel der universität
zürich
das resultat von 20 jahren
beharrlichkeit und unbeirrbaren
enthusiasmus am schönste ich für mich
punkte hat wo mein publikum hat ihre
blüten frau und ihr freund war nicht
sauber und was man sich anbieter geehrt
magath liegt dinosaurier selber
aufzuspüren und auszugraben war für
biber von anfang an teil des abenteuers
sein jagdgebiet der westen der usa
sievers funde fast komplette skelette
haben schon für furore gesorgt und den
usa bis in den fernen osten
das waren noch zeiten also immer
durchgeführt japanern mehr so dringend
app ist spektakulär es finden und hand
nachher dann das noch auf anrufe gemacht
und so hoffe ich dass mir jetzt wieder
es toll findet
tage später ist sie war unterwegs in
colorado mit seinem altgedienten bein
und zwei mitstreitern in den weiten des
westens hier ist der saunen jäger in
seinem element
vor möglichkeit auch noch unentdeckte
schätze oder musik geht ich bin nicht
überzogen dass das also noch unter die
dusche gehen vermutet dass alles gelegt
hat und dass die irgendwo darum regiert
die frage ist bloß wo genau haben sie
sich versteckt
die mission dieser saison ist es eine
neue lohnenswerte grabungsstelle zu
finden
[Musik]
die letzte fundstelle musste sie
aufgeben weil der landbesitzer immer
mehr geld forderte ein amerikanischer
freund aus alten tagen hat ihm auf
seinem land eine stelle angeboten wo vor
vier jahren bereits sind sauer gefunden
worden ist
eine woche hat köbi 7 und zeit für eine
test grabung um dann zu entscheiden ober
in den nächsten jahren zeit geld und
energie in diesen steinbuch investieren
will
für die erkundung erziehbar nur ein
kleines team mitgenommen
thomas bolliger geologe und vize
direktor des museums und urs möglich
freier fotograf der seit jahren für sie
bearbeitet dinosaurier ausgaben ist eine
mischung aus baustellenarbeit und
feinmechanischen dreck
ich habe es geht liegt dort eine doch
spaß macht
man sucht quasi die nadel in steinhaufen
und keiner weiß aber hier gerade den
richtigen quadratmeter gestein umgräbt
und weg pinselt
[Musik]
ja so schön madeira die idee aufwächst
es ist jetzt zu hause schön so geht es
da dass er aber es ist ein ziemlich
großer da so macht spaß der hundertfach
gebrochene knochen muss sofort geräumt
werden damit keine splitter verloren
gehen
das jagdfieber ist entfacht jetzt zeit
sparen
die hand dann brauche man jetzt aber
noch eine gewisse der 14 gehört oder
nicht
jetzt wird ist es gut aus oder super
zeichen aber wir müssen noch etwas dazu
musste werden
billigjeans notierte der auch noch den
zuschnitt
aber vielleicht ist elite ganzes
catering
das ist spannend ist zu uns gekommen
[Musik]
doch körper weiß auch die größte tugend
des dinosaurier jägers ist viel geduld
[Musik]
man kann den skeletten auch mit gruppen
geschützt zu leibe rücken
[Musik]
der landbesitzer team hat räumt die
gesteinsmassen oberhalb der knochen
haltigen schicht weg mit
fingerspitzengefühl
[Musik]
sollte rufen pro verbrauchter so gut
und das täglich zu lassen
aber er fliegt also ist nicht weiter
tragisch aber es hilft da ist ein enorm
zu müssen und funk liegt
den großen skelett und macht das
mechanische monster nicht
zurück zur handarbeit trotzdem ist die
kunst des zusammenflicken bald gefragt
eine angst bröckelige knochensubstanz
wird bei dieser grabung zu
spielverderber es basiere dauern
es ist ein konflikt
das ist mir sagen wo studieren
traunstein vernünftige wochen aus aber
das ist ein job damit auf dem kopf
getragen werden ich habe mich auch nie
zu wahrscheinlich das muss man
vertraglich eine das alles hat mir sein
und ganz beim ersten anlauf nicht halt
ich hoffe ich bin 2007 zweiter auf dem
grid und sowie der business hat
[Musik]
das ist zeitraubend doch was sind schon
stunden und tage im angesicht von 150
millionen jahre alten knochen
[Musik]
die meditative arbeit unter freiem
himmel zusammen mit gleichgesinnten ist
aber für sieber lebenselixier
ich bin hier im büro man sie einmal
besitzer und den computer starten das
ist dass sie wenn ich mich auch siebels
privatleben verlief nicht in
konventionellen bahnen drei jahre
verheiratet von zwei ehefrauen hat er
vier töchtern dinosauriern aber ist er
seit jahrzehnten treu auch wenn sie
nicht immer leicht zu haben sind
o
auch
das tun sie wohl
es bleibt zeit für eine ausfahrt über
die staatsgrenze nach utah
das diner sorge national monument ist
eine grabungsstelle über die ein museum
gestülpt worden ist
seit anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
wurden hier dutzende von skeletten
freigelegt ein teil davon ist den fund
lage im gestein belassen
diesen ort sei aggressiver zum ersten
mal als 22 jähriger nach einem
studienjahr in den usa reist der mitte
der 60er quer durchs land und landete
auch hier das hat nicht zu tief
beeindruckt
wir haben das fantastisch kunde dass man
endlich mal zeit wie die dinosaurier
sind
das ist wirklich dass ich das hat mich
begeistert und ich mein wunsch
entstanden eines tages sauberer sondern
unglaublich style.de und hätte mir
natürlich näher vorgestellt dass er
eines tages nicht nur einen uns glauben
sondern geradeaus glaube und zum teil
sogar city geworden besser sind als wir
da jetzt
sievers faszination für die urwaldriesen
ist bis zum heutigen tag ungebrochen
er sieht in den dinosaurier knochen die
zeitlose ästhetik der natur
das ist etwas wunderschönes faktor
funktionalität jedoch noch nicht perfekt
ins bild dass es innerhalb von einem
organismus dienstleisters muss leichter
aber nicht wichtig ist dass aus um
menschenrechte für das wunderschön und
[Musik]
nach zwei jahrzehnten eigene ausgaben
erfahrung weiß sie heute auch den wert
dieser ausstellung noch mehr zu schätzen
das sind 100 die dose gefärbt stunde
trinkt das steht auch ziemlich hart und
ich weiß wie viel arbeit das das
bedeutet das nicht so haben wir das
damals so repräsentiert das da
wahrscheinlich 20 jahre arbeit und das
ist wirklich als monument für
wissenschaft
[Musik]
auch die eigene grabungsstelle
entwickelt sich gegen 40 knochen sind
nach fünf tagen frei gelegt vor allem
wirbel von pflanzenfressern
aber erst wenn mehr als 50 prozent eines
einzelnen tieres beisammen liegen wird
der fund für sieber überhaupt
interessant
mindestens 150 zusammengehörige knochen
wären das ziel
davon ist man im moment noch weit
entfernt eine einzelne rapper etwa ist
für sie aber kaum die arbeitszeit wird
man sie braucht
die konzert über im zusammenhang mit
skelett und ohne jetzt aber hat sich gar
keine bedeutung da haben wir die ganze
burg schweizer dazu treiben einige der
gefundenen knochen teile auch einen
erfahrenen gräber zur verzweiflung
das heißt es hat da teile die heimat
führen wie das wetter ist
und dann hat es da ein schlichtes
wendland hat jeder und tröste ich hoffe
dass gewesen also auch die 12
sie bewusst mit dem landbesitzer
aushandeln ob er sich unter diesen
umständen für die nächsten jahre auf der
grabungsstelle verpflichtet mit den
entsprechenden mietkosten der
finanzielle spielraum für solche
investitionen ist knapp ich hoffe
wirklich dass die qualität der knochen
noch besser wird das ist ein wichtiger
punkt wir brauchen ja mindestens 50 oder
60 prozent eines skeletts das kann man
jetzt natürlich noch nicht sagen nein
dafür war die zeit zu kurz man einigt
sich darauf dass das seeba team im
kommenden jahr nochmals eine test
grabung durchführen und dann entscheiden
kann
[Musik]
der letzte tag der grabung ist bereits
dem aufräumen und zusammenpacken
gewidmet die vorläufige beute wird
verstaut
[Musik]
doch ein rätsel willkür wie sie bei noch
lösen er hat die enden von massiven
knochen freigelegt dir nicht eindeutig
zuordnen kann möglicherweise das knie
und teile des bein seines riesigen
pflanzenfresser das kranke sich dass es
selbst große wird wird es kurios
funktion rauch und bin war vorerst noch
verwegener bis es war absolut up
gigantisches monster aber etwas passen
nicht richtig passt gar nicht richtig
ohne abschließende erkenntnis müssen die
gräber die fundstelle winterfest machen
in der ungewissheit ob sie mit diesem
ort wirklich auf den richtigen sound
gesetzt haben sicher auch noch der
motivation tut es keinen abbruch
es macht das spaß ich glaube es hat
jeder tag hat irgendwie spannend
überraschend sei und eigentlich muss man
dass man vor deinen augen korrektur über
hunt aber einmal es nicht sofort jetzt
gab die nasa erwartet
nach dem mühseligen freilegen werden die
knochen samt ihren schwierigkeiten und
fragezeichen unterbrachen schutt und
staub wieder begraben
[Musik]
erwachsen
das ist sehr dringend
raus in den sternen
[Musik]
zurück im museum
hier werden die funde der vergangenen
jahre präpariert alle gesteins reste
entfernt und knochenteile
zusammengesetzt regelmäßig braucht es
knochen inventur um den überblick nicht
zu verlieren
die einzelteile eines langhals sauriers
werden zusammengetragen das resultat der
letzten fünf jahre grabung und
präparation im sommer soll der 27 meter
lange gigant erstmals in genf
ausgestellt werden soll man da wirklich
tolle yolanda die älteste von sivers
vier töchtern arbeitet als präparator in
für das sauriermuseum sie hat einen teil
des skeletts in ihrer eigenen werkstatt
in zug bearbeitet und präsentiert jetzt
die resultate
der shop bestellen 23 ist es wohl anders
mit dinosauriern aufgewachsen
sie musste aber auch lernen ihren vater
stets mit den urvätern zu teilen
aber ich okay so also mit kann ja gar
nicht ahnt ist das völlig normal
arevalo heizkörpers neuester liebling
benannt nach einem indianerstamm für
diesen sommer überhaupt noch einen platz
im museum zu finden wird schwierig
wichtig ist jetzt der schwanz detail
vorstellt kommt es dort haus fördert
gigantischste was separat liegt allein
der hals ist gegen zehn meter lang und
die räume stoßen an die grenze ihres
fassungsvermögens innerhalb von 20
jahren hat sieber sie mit einer
einmaligen sammlung gefüllt wie er das
gewicht dieses lebenswerks auf andere
schultern verteilen kann muss er sich im
alter von 73 jahren gelegentlich
überlegen doch dass jemand aus dem team
mit gleichem einsatz die volle
verantwortung auf sich nimmt ist
unwahrscheinlich
dritte zu fuß konnte mit uns der
republik hat sich mit dem priorität
haben im moment ohnehin europahaus alte
knochen um ihn auf die beine zu bringen
braucht es alle verfügbaren kräfte
dann kann man statt in die vergangenheit
weiter in die zukunft schauen aber
vorläufig macht mir spaß und ich bin
sicher dass ich noch einiges verbringen
mithalten einer verantworten und das
spart im nachgang haben also ich habe
eigentlich erst mit über 50
die eigentliche beruf gefunden und
sollte es doch eigentlich ein ereignis
wer wie kirby sieber in jahrmillionen
denkt hat es auch mit der eigenen
pensionierung nicht allzu eilig
[Musik]